i'm joined today by iraq war veteran and
Purple Heart recipient will Fisher who's
the executive director of the Union
veterans council through afl-cio he's
been traveling the country talking to
veterans and other voters about what a
Donald Trump presidency would mean for
veterans and military families and I
want to start of will by getting suit
your reaction to the caricature we often
see the idea of Republican strong on the
military democrat week when it comes to
the military is that even anything we
should be remotely paying attention to
in evaluating policy with regard to our
veterans anymore or has that gone out
the window I think it really is
something that never really existed so a
lot of that was born out of you know at
the end of the Vietnam War and I believe
that you know a lot of people saw
especially in the early 80s through you
know some of the grandstanding done by
President Reagan and some of the pomp
and circumstance around the military
that somehow being strong in the fence
meant that you were strong and stood
with veterans which is absolutely not
the case I mean right now do you have
the Republicans in Congress who are
trying to destroy and privatize the VA
for instance you have Republicans in
Congress who want to do away with the GI
Bill right you have Republicans in
Congress we want to cut pay for active
duty military and it extends of course
well beyond the actions of the Congress
because right now we have in a the
republican party's nominee for president
united states in Donald Trump someone
who look very rarely embraces any policy
any policy when it comes to veterans and
military families and our active service
and when he does it's things like doing
away with the GI Bill it's things like
seni wants to destroy and privatize the
VA it's things like speaking in a very
charlatan manner
or a very Cavalier manner about using
nuclear weapons but it goes so much
deeper than that with mr. Trump you know
this is someone who is also spent a year
on the campaign trail attacking our
military insulting veterans saying that
people like John McCain and other
prisoners of war are losers because they
were captured someone who compares their
sex life in the 80s and 90s to serving
in combat in Vietnam someone who says
that when young women and men get him by
roadside bombs I just go for a little
ride in the air someone who attacks gold
star families I mean where are we in our
politics where we have somebody out
there in this case it's republican
party's nominee for president attacking
gold star families people have already
sacrificed more than many can even begin
to imagine well a lot of signs uh in
thinking of of this sort of line of
thinking that you're that you're talking
talking to us about this comment that
Donald Trump made which he's now chalked
up to some kind of joke which was he's
always wanted a purple heart and he was
handed a physical one by a veteran at an
event some time ago uh as you know we
don't have to speculate about what that
meant to a Purple Heart recipient we can
actually just ask you did you find that
offensive or did you find it to be the
light-hearted joke that Donald Trump
claimed it to be once people said hey
you know you might want to block that
back you know I think that what happened
is someone asked me the exact same
question you just now did about 10
minutes after mr. Trump made those
comments and I was so struck by what he
said that I immediately just said the
first thing that came to mind for me and
the first thing came to mind for me when
I heard Donald Trump said he had always
wanted a purple heart was all this in
nineteen 2004 you see on that day
outside of the city of Fallujah I was
awarded a Purple Heart but so was my
Marine Corps brother who got his arm
blown off so was my Marine Corps brother
who lost Anna and so was my Marine Corps
brother who was killed that day and he
didn't when they will receive his Purple
Heart his widow had to receive it on his
behalf and you know I guess what Donald
didn't learn
in that elite military prep school he
attended is that purple hearts are
reminders of very bad days and nobody
nobody out there that has one ever
wanted it you know and I think it's also
important to remember that this is
somebody who makes these comments about
veterans who makes these comments about
our military who categorically at the
same time wants to send more young
American women and men in the combat but
it won't be his kids right I don't think
anybody thinks that Donnie jr. Eric or
vodka are gonna put on a flak jacket
anytime soon but if Donald Trump is
elected president the people out there
listening today their kids will and the
people who they work with their kids
will in the people that they worship
with the participating community
activities with their kids will and it's
mighty bold talk mighty bold talk come
from somebody who died service uh when
it was their time to serve with the help
of multiple deferments and having a Rich
Dad well along those lines you know I
this is a little bit of a departure from
trump specifically and and it's more
just a commentary on what we started
with which is this idea of I support the
troops you don't support the troops as
president here's how I would support the
troops and very very often that that
becomes a phrase that not only lacks
meaning but it actually sometimes takes
on opposite meaning and very very often
supporting the troops is is uh wrapped
up with uh sending troops into
engagements that are sometimes primarily
sometimes partially motivated by
political gain and political posturing
and I feel like that is not discussed
enough the idea that the number one way
to really value the volunteer service
all of our our troops is not to ever use
troops for political battles or in areas
where it is not absolutely necessary and
I feel like that frank conversation is
not had enough I don't know how you feel
about that absolutely I think that one
thing that is important to understand
that we always try to focus on is
lifting up the fact that the veteran
class and the working
s are one in the same that the veteran
class and the working class are one in
the same into your point look make no
mistake about it right make no mistake
about it the exact same people who are
more than willing to send the working
class all over this world to fight wars
with our blood are very often the exact
same people who are more than willing to
amass fortunes up the sweat and labor of
veterans once we get back home you know
somebody it's easy for a politician to
stand up in a truck bed or on the stage
giving a speech and talk about how much
they support veterans I mean anybody can
say that I support the troops I want to
honor the sacrifice of troops and
veterans look I put them in my TV
commercials etc but then how often are
those exact same people who we hear so
loudly talk about how much they support
veterans the exact same people who work
day in and day out to do things like
destroy and privatize the VA to get rid
of veterans job training and education
benefits like the GI Bill but also do
not veterans on the ability to have a
voice on the job the ability to
collectively bargain and have access to
a career to a good job that allows a
veteran to live with life with dignity
and live out the American dream that we
fought to protect and defend you know
then that's something that I think very
important also in this race for the
presidency Hillary Clinton does not view
veterans or the working class as
political props rather she looks as
human beings right that's why his first
lady it was Hillary Clinton new chimp
was raising awareness around issues
affecting Gulf War veterans that's why I
was cinder Hillary Clinton who was
championing legislation like the 21st
century GI bill and it will be president
Hillary Clinton will work to expand
veterans job training benefits education
benefits and under no circumstances
allow our VA to be destroyed and
privatized and even deeper than that
going back to a point I just now made
Secretary Clinton fundamentally
understands that what a veteran needs
access to more than anything upon
returning home is not a yellow ribbon
it's not a standing ovation at a
football game
what a veteran needs access to more than
anything is a good job in a good job
allows that person live a life with
dignity will in the limited time we have
left uh yesterday i was watching this
town hall or recently i was watching
this town hall that president obama did
with members of the military and i
picked up on some pretty significant
skepticism from many of the of the
troops in the room who clearly were
being respectful to the president but
they had questions that were if not
adversarial certainly evidence that they
were very skeptical of the president's
policies not specifically about this
town hall but generally what I'm curious
to hear from you is what types of
statements from politicians about troops
veterans the military etc are concerning
type statements for you where you say
you know that I'm hearing a talking
point that is a talking point that is is
concerning to me and what types of
statements from politicians are the ones
that you are more likely to stay here as
though that could be a good thing mm-hmm
I think it's a great question i think
the ones that make me the most wary are
very often the ones that you hear from
these folks that are always banging
banging the drum for more war when they
use their quote unquote support for
troops as a an opportunity to make
inroads into talking about going into
more wars and creating more veterans
right and i think the ones that the
conversations that veterans are
interested in conversations veterans
want to have go back to those class
issues what r is this elected official
doing to enable me to join with my
fellow veterans to join with my fellow
you know working class neighbors and
colleagues to build out a better life
for ourselves and live out the kind of
life that that we want that we need and
that every person should be entitled to
i think that when you look at Donald
Trump
this is someone who Tom and Tom again
has shown that he has no real plans
whatsoever you hear him talking about
the military you hear him talking about
veterans and what does he talk about he
says our military is full of losers
right he I don't even need to rehash all
of the anti veteran statements that he's
made thus far even though there are
plenty more in that reservoir this is
someone who also alienate our allies on
a daily basis this is someone who also
for some weird reason has this obsession
including in the debate to the night of
seizing every opportunity he can to fan
dance for a you know an authoritarian
dictator in Vladimir Putin Donald Trump
is categorically unprepared to be
President of the United States he's
mendacious he's capricious he's a
chickenhawk charlatan and he knows
nothing of what veterans and the working
class in this country face and he has no
plan to bring about the changes that we
need Hillary Clinton on the other hand
is aptly prepared to be Prezi nited
states a commander-in-chief she has a
plan to keep Americans safe she has
appertain a plan to defeat our enemies
and a plan to bring people together to
make those things happen and Hillary
Clinton also as a plan and has a track
record of standing with veterans and
with the working class and that will
continue long after she's occupying the
Oval Office we have been speaking with
Iraq war veteran and Purple Heart
recipient will Fisher executive director
of the Union veterans council through
afl-cio will thanks so much for talking
to me today I can't thank you enough i
look forward to doing it again sometime